we are back with a fox news alert
outrage growing in our nation's capital
as thousands of national guard members
have reportedly been
forced to rest during their breaks
inside parking garages
florida governor ron desantis just
announced that he ordered his
state's troops to come home okay and the
governor joins us right now
live from saint pete down in florida
governor good morning to you
good morning you know a lot of people
have looked at those images of these
people who the
national guardsmen who have been in our
nation's capital to make sure that the
inauguration was nice and secure
and they were sleeping on the floor of
the capitol and then somebody kicked him
out and said go sleep in the garage
uh nap wise during your breaks i know
you were
infuriated and that's why you officially
called people back
last night and it was announced this
morning
yeah that's right steve i mean these
folks are soldiers they've served our
country
all around the world they've served our
state of florida after natural disasters
they're serving right now helping with
vaccinating senior citizens and they've
been on the front lines of the covid
fight
they're soldiers they're not nancy
pelosi servants and this comes on the
back end
of them trying to investigate the
backgrounds of our guardsmen
florida we did not let them go into
their political beliefs i thought that
was totally inappropriate
i thought it was very disrespectful for
people who are clearly patriots
so this is a half [ __ ] mission at this
point and i think the appropriate thing
is to bring them home
yeah so governor uh as far as the
vaccine is concerned
there are so many new yorkers all of us
have friends that have moved down to
florida
are temporarily living down there and
zooming their kids with school because
they want to be in the sunshine and
you've done you know you're opening
everything up so they're loving it down
in florida
but uh we talked about it on air one day
that you were allowing people from other
states
to get the vaccines there and i called
just fly down from new york fly from
canada fly from south america there are
a lot of those yeah we're doing that
yeah and that's totally yeah that's
totally not true
that's totally not true because we've
done about 1.3 million
yeah we've done about 1.3 million
reported vaccine shots probably
hundreds of thousands of more because
there's a reporting lag 97 percent have
been full-time florida residents
we do have people who are part-time
residents and so if you have a home you
pay taxes you live here over the winter
that's different a lot of them have
doctors here there's no vaccine tourism
hospitals are not permitted to engage in
vaccine tourism
if there's a one or two off where
someone didn't follow the rules and
that's something we deal with
but this is we're putting our seniors
first and we're putting our florida
seniors first
governor you mentioned the amount of
people vaccinated in the state of
florida and it is leading leading the
nation and
in fact the percentage of the vaccine
administered to seniors in florida
nearly 65 percent over 500 000
individuals
in the state at least have received the
vaccine what are you doing differently
that's allowing you to vaccinate so many
more
of the vulnerable population
well pete i appreciate it it's even
better than that so we're reporting
about 840 000 seniors as of this morning
have received the shot but
the reporting lags about three days of
what we found so we really believe
today is the day that we're going to do
our 1 millionth senior
in the state of florida i have a world
war ii veteran here that you guys are
going to see get this shot he's 100
years old
henry sailor great guy what we did pete
we will but what we did pete is we said
seniors first
okay this is something we need to focus
on the 65
and up population there's young healthy
workers that are getting it in other
states
god bless them but i want to protect our
vulnerable so that's what we're doing
we've got sites in all 67 counties we're
working with pharmacies
we're working with hospitals and if you
doubled my vaccine allotment next week i
would be able to do double
the vaccines why aren't we getting the
vaccine sorry steve to interrupt you but
really quickly what is it are they just
not manufacturing them enough
enough time look i mean i think it's i
think the federal government when they
get them they send them
uh but i think we thought we'd be
getting a little bit more
by now i'm getting about 266 000 a week
for example lanesley last week the full
week monday through sunday
we did 405 000 shots and so
i'm now doing more shots in a week than
i'm getting replenished for
and so if we don't start to see
increases in the supply
then you will actually see fewer
vaccines done on a daily basis
although we do got one right here are
you guys ready to see yeah
henry saylor okay
all right 100 years old army air corps
veteran
he's a world war ii veteran he's 100
years old
he's had a remarkable career of service
to our country into the state of florida
he was a state senator here
he knew charles lindbergh he knew he
knows
boss aldrin joe dimaggio presidents uh
from
truman to reagan um and he's an american
hero
he's 100 years old and he's got the
opportunity now to get the vaccine so
we're excited
and we do believe this is the one
millionth senior
which the reporting will bear out over
the next couple days
oh there it goes okay okay i know he
can't
he can't hear us governor but he's so
strong yeah i can ask him a question
yeah just ask him how that felt
hey henry how did that feel i didn't
feel a thing
okay
that's the right answer
this guy's still got some guns i mean he
came in showed that
let me tell you 100 years old i watched
every lady look at him
this is a handsome individual and people
know it so
we agree governor if you would uh to
please pass our thanks to henry for his
service and what does it mean to him
to get the back yeah henry would like to
say hi can he say hi to you guys real
quick
i'll say how happy we are to live in the
number one state
in the union and have the number one
governor in in the union
well that's true
hey governor could you ask him uh how he
being a hundred has been hunkered down
for the last year trying to
uh you know minimize the exposure yeah
and
and what he has missed i mean he can't
be around his family he can't be around
a lot of friends because you never know
who's got it
and how did you handle when covet hit
have you been isolating have you been
able to see friends and family what did
you do
oh yes we've seen friends and family uh
it's it's things are not normal at least
at age 100 but uh
we've been very close to normal and we
got his son allen here
um who's uh who's helping as well so
yeah i know look i think what
i think henry's umbelmeck a lot of
floridians you know this is real
they obviously take precautions but he's
um you know he's lived a full life and
he's going to keep living and obviously
this vaccine
will help him even do more even more i
wonder in his lifetime in his 100 years
if he's ever experienced anything like
this i'm sure not
well what did he experience he just said
he didn't feel a thing
well governor thank you thank henry on
our behalf for his service and for uh
for showing the world thank you for your
service and thanks for doing this
thanks absolutely he says thanks guys
all right
governor i believe you vote i believe
governor you owe him breakfast
after that great endorsement
that's a deal all right thank you
governor thank you governor
and thank you mr sailor for your service
thank you